big thank you to the sponsors of this
video revolut and if you sign up with
revolut using my link in the description
below you will be getting a free 20
pound bonus into your account two
minutes work for 20 quid not bad revolut
is the one app that you need for all
things money it's an easy new way to
help you manage your finances and not
only do you manage your finances you get
a lot of things added with that as well
you can get up to forty percent off
brands like nike adidas amazon
hellofresh and loads of other brands
these are bespoke discounts that you
will not find anywhere else latest kits
for the season huge savings last minute
summer holidays i've got you covered me
it's worth downloading just for that
they also make traveling easier and
cheaper with no hidden fees and amazing
exchange rates and with me in the lads
from the kick off heading to barcelona
soon we've used revolut to book our
hotels at exclusive rates with no
booking fees and they give you up to 10
cashback with the metal plan all through
the app it's a no-brainer at this point
on top of that with the metal plan you
can also earn up to 1.2 percent cashback
on all purchases when you're abroad
based on your subscription as well as
being covered for delayed flights and
baggage insurance but despite all those
great things my favorite thing about
this is how simple and easy it makes
life for me in managing the money so you
can get your own metal card also and
it's customizable so you know you can
put something on there that you like so
help us out by supporting the people
that support this channel download
revolut using my link in the description
below but for now enjoy the video
breaking news it's not really like
breaking news like russia have invaded
ukraine it's not that jake paul versus
tommy fury is off again
for the second time yeah it's a weird
one because a lot of people were talking
[__] about this fight like yeah it's a
nothing fight who cares whatever you
know they're both not very great at
boxing water you can't deny the hype it
was there do you know when like um
you've ordered a takeaway and it's like
any minute now oh can't wait and then
you're like sort of looking out the
window and you're like oh it can't be
long now ah i'm not going to tip him you
ring him he goes i'm just coming around
the corner i think i haven't even tell
you what i'm complaining about yet
you're lying and that's an option here
someone might be lying but the point is
it's not getting delivered should we
just give up i think i'm close to giving
up it's not life really let alone the
fight he broke a rib last time a lot of
people think it was because of his
brother the heavyweight champion of the
world tyson fury 20 stone man pile
driving a medicine bowling that was gut
and therefore potentially breaking a rib
now this time it's not an injury because
he's not allowed into america why well
it might have something to do with tyson
fury again i'm just after getting off
the phone with daniel kinnahan he just
informed me that
the biggest fighting british box in
history has just been agreed get up
there my boy
tyson fury versus anthony joshua um next
year another fight that never never
happened boxing there like i love it but
it's a load of shite sometimes big thank
you dan for getting this deal over the
line who the [__] is daniel kinnehan
well we gotta do a little digging not
too much digging god knows what we'll
find
joseph kinnan was born in june 1977.
well we don't need his fun life story do
we let's just get to the point where he
becomes a crime boss and was named in
the irish high court as a senior figure
in global organized crime this isn't
good fellas daniel controlled and
managed mckinnahan cartel smuggling
drugs and firearms into ireland the uk
and mainland europe okay i think i think
we've i don't want to cover too much
there's one thing pissing youtubers off
i'll do that in my sleep this man i'm
gonna leave it at that let's just
leave it where it is the fbi are looking
for him for a start and i don't want him
showing up at my garth it's the links to
daniel kanahan which have this time cost
tommy a shot at jake paul and of course
securing the bag he was supposed to be
getting over two million for this fight
i think the problem is is because he
pulled out the first time and because of
again the fight falling through because
of him this time people are going to
call him a bottle job the problem is
this is actually being predicted well
i'm out
this will be the last time i talk to you
guys about jake paul versus will fury
let's just talk about a few things yeah
this was two weeks ago when this fight
was first announced and yes that was
chael sonnen calling tommy fury will
flurry which he has done for months now
and it's [__] funny and if his name's
fleury i'm i'm not trying to condescend
i'm not trying to be a jerk like that
i'm just sure
i'm not comfortable that telling you
guys
on august 13th live from madison square
guard you are going to see jake paul
verse i'm not i don't think he's going
to show up and that's the problem here
is he isn't showing up so this is just
adding further to all of the people who
are calling tommy fury a bottle job i'm
not but a lot of people are tommy you
know for whatever reason couldn't get in
ridiculous i mean you know he went to
the you know he'd only been out in the
states was it four or five weeks ago and
then he gets the you know and the bottom
line is he's got to go to the embassy
and sort it out so so frank warren
confirms that tommy fury needs to go to
the embassy and sort it out everyone's
saying he just needs to go at the
embassy and sort it out that sounds
fairly simple when you say it like that
just pop down to the embassy put your
poor stamp on pop the letter through the
door and bob's your uncle you're off to
america i'm assuming it's probably not
that simple forgive me if i'm wrong but
tommy fury doesn't strike me as the kind
of guy
who
would be the best at sorting out this
sort of level of matter like and i don't
mean that in a condescending way i'm not
saying he's got sodas for brains he's a
boxer he's not someone who should be
dealing with the american embassy the
problem is is
jake paul called him out on this jake
calls out tommy and says he's out of the
fight by wednesday morning if he doesn't
go to the embassy slash come out of
hiding now obviously that's not happened
the fight is now off but tommy has not
communicated at all on the run-up to all
of these problems he could have been
doing videos going this is what i'm
trying to do this is where we're at show
transparency and show willingness to
fight because although i fully believe
tommy is a fighter and he's willing to
fight the public want to say that want
to hear that when i feel that jake's
doing all these videos calling him out
tommy's silent it's not a good look but
tommy has finally responded now that
jake has confirmed he's not fighting him
anymore and again you wait until you're
no longer fighting to do a response and
then of all the responses you could have
done instead of showing your face and
talking and saying i'm angry i'm
frustrated i really want this fight i
can't wait to [__] this guy up make us
believe that you still really wanted
that fight he puts out some little note
that he made i'm not angry
just disappointed all right i'm gutted
and disappointed in regards to the
issues i have faced with entry into the
usa this is something that for myself or
my team could never have anticipated
happening i do think john fury probably
seen this coming a little bit like if
there's one person who understands legal
problems and getting into america it's
big john and maybe this makes a little
more sense now with why john was so
eager to not have the fight in america
the situation has been left with my
lawyers as being denied entry to a
country is obviously very serious issue
and needs to be subsequently resolved i
just don't know if he wrote that just
can't imagine tommy using the word
subsequently can you i'm confident this
fight will happen you're the only one
paul this fight could be made another 10
times and there'll be something go wrong
someone's getting cancer
it's literally ridiculous at this point
in the winter i want to clarify that i
will fight in a neutral country that
both parties can enter any time any
place anywhere aside from america which
we've clarified because he can't get
into it because of dan the man who set
the aj versus fury fight up that also
never happened it's just the most
ridiculous [__] this isn't it maybe we
can find a way dan is right now because
he could put the fight on and then the
fbi could get a hold of him everyone
goes home happy aside from dan who
obviously will be going to prison well
that's tommy [__] jake paul on the
other hand looks like he's fighting
someone quite serious and this could be
a problem really because i think this
guy is actually more dangerous than
tommy from memory hassine ratman jr
versus jake paul is being finalized
hassin ratman obviously the man who
knocked out lennox lewis back in the day
and subsequently lost to lennox in the
rematch via knockout his son is a very
decent fighter by all accounts those who
know the youtube boxing scene we'll know
vidal riley absolute beast just scored a
great knockout he was actually supposed
to be lined up to fight this guy which
shows sort of the level we're talking
about here it's certainly not a bomb
rackman came in at 224 pounds for his
fight with morrison jake paul weighs in
around 191.94
so this will be a fight against a bigger
man so we got a guy who's way
bigger than jake paul here and got a
record of 12-0 before this fight
with a big reach if jake was here i'd be
like are you sure you want to do this
this is a guy who's been bred into
this by a world champion father and a
guy who knocked out lennox lewis by the
way not like someone who just squeaked a
world title yeah this is the real
[__] deal yeah so to be fair i get it
like you've gone from one boxing family
to another but
all right round one there we go
that same dream comes out smartly with
the j yep yeah the guy is [__]
massive like the first thing he's
naturally much bigger than jake paul
this guy he's got a good job he's got a
good thudding job in the [__]
forehead there after that punch rock man
i had a different demeanor it looks like
those those punches what i will say is
the guy doesn't look the fittest he's a
heavyweight but if he actually got in
shape he'd probably be able to make
cruiser that that's obviously where this
would be for that but he's massive
compared to jake like he's got a chin on
him as well he's taking some licks here
and he's just thrown back he's a bit of
a dog by the looks of it now he looks
like his daddy and whatever rocky movie
oh that one hurts
[Applause]
okay so he is vulnerable but he is still
a big [__] like all right he got
dropped there but like i think he gets
up here
[Applause]
i think he's okay minute before he's
done
he's not okay he's not okay one shot
will take him out he's not okay one shot
take him out he's smiling morrison's
nice he's not okay he's got a minute and
a half
he's not okay yeah wow
i like the way he just stumped his feet
interestingly they've spawned together
before this and jake has obviously felt
like in that spot he's seen enough to
make him think you know i could [__]
beat this guy
this is a very good fight that jay can
put together short notice you got to
respect the balls on jake at some point
right the people have wanted a real
boxer this is a real [__] boxer i
don't wanna hear any [__] about oh it's
not a real it's a real boxer and a guy
who's bigger than him who had more
experience than him has probably been
trained since he was a [__] kid by
his dad this is legit what we had in
tommy we've got that and then some in
this guy maybe he might not be as good
as tommy is in terms of actual boxing in
the ring i don't know but the guy is a
big dude like this is a test i think if
jake beats him he'll get what he's
looking for which is respect tommy on
the other hand i don't know what the
[__] he must be thinking right now so
we have a fight on our hands it's jake
paul this is hassim ratman jr from
madison square gardens i'm looking
forward to it don't forget hit that like
button stay subscribe to the true jordy
youtube channel for more
thanks for watching and i'll see you
later